[Applause]
china celebrated the 100th anniversary
of its ruling communist party on july
1st
this anniversary is really a moment for
the chinese communist party to be able
to look back on how far it's come
from a party that was more or less ruled
out as a potential power player
into the driving force behind the
country that is now the world's second
largest economy
and on pace to be its number one economy
xi jinping really wants to take this
moment and say
china has arrived
[Applause]
nobody thought that the ccp would be
this successful
um when it was founded in 1921 whether
it be in science technology
and sports in the economy in almost
every facet
china's stronger than it's been in the
past and in a sense they're really going
to give
the us and the west a run for its money
we're in a race with china and the rest
of the world for the 21st century
they're not waiting they're investing
tens of billions of dollars across the
board
but to surpass the u.s china will have
to overcome several challenges
this is a time when china's economy is
recovering from the coronavirus pandemic
earlier than everywhere else and that's
left china looking pretty strong
its economy is expected to grow by 8.5
this year and it was gaining ground not
only in the us but it was
adding ground between itself and many of
its neighbors
it was able to take advantage of the
demand for exports all around the world
when people needed ppe when people
needed medical equipment when people
needed
computer equipment it's made big leaps
in mobile payments
artificial intelligence quantum
computing and even sending a rover to
mars
so part of the strength of the chinese
state over the last 30 to 40 years has
been based on its economy it's grown so
quickly
and with a massive population it had
both a large
base of labor as well as a huge market
for western companies and other foreign
companies to move into china what we're
starting to see now
is that some of that economic growth is
slowing namely you
have a population in china that is
spewing older and older
chinese demographers believe that china
really has about a 10 15
year window here before things start to
get really bad in terms of
the number of people that you have
working trying to support
x number of people who are retired so
one of the measures that the chinese
government has taken
was to allow chinese people to have more
babies that's because
for the better part of the last four
decades china has
restricted most families to only having
one child
one of the most important priorities for
xi jinping has been ensuring that
china's periphery is secure
it has xinjiang it has hong kong and
we've seen very strong controls put in
place there over the past few years to
really make sure that beijing's will is
first and foremost
beijing has drawn global scrutiny for
its use of surveillance technology to
keep an eye on people's activities in
xinjiang
and hong kong beijing has said that
national security concerns in hong kong
have required it to take stronger
measures in the city
chinese authorities have defended the
use of surveillance in xinjiang as
designed to promote development and
security for locals
they have an overall goal to become the
leading country in the world
the wealthiest country in the world and
the most powerful country in the world
that's not going to happen on my watch
rhetoric has actually been very tough
since he became president
he said that genocide is what is
happening in
xinjiang dhs is deeply concerned by
credible and growing reports of china's
state-sponsored use of forced labor and
other human rights violations
in the xinjiang region
foreign
his predecessor he wants to work with
other democracies to stand up to
autocratic governments like china's
it seems like in washington biden has
now reflected
and captured the zeitgeist there that
says
china is fundamentally different from us
in terms of the values
and they're gaining ground on us in a
way that we should be very worried about
over the next 10 to 15 years she has
made it very clear that he wants to
build
self-sufficiency i think he's recognized
that china is too reliant in some ways
on the west in areas like semiconductors
and technologies with military
applications and china is definitely
doing things in its own way
it stepped up control of big and
powerful tech companies
such as the fintech giant ant and how it
handles the user data that it generates
[Music]
and wants is for china to be able to
keep its prosperity but
also be more ideologically committed
to the communist underpinning that first
inspired
the founders of the communist party here
in china
and he also wants a country where the
people are
going to be more loyal to china than
they have been in the past